Phoenix vor Ort
herzlich Willkommen zu Phoenix vor Ort
meine Damen und Herren sie merken es wir
halten Sie auf dem laufenden rund um die
chaotischen Zustände in Russland der
Maske Machtkampf zwischen dem
Söldnerführer Krieg und der
Militärführung in Moskau spitzt sich zu
bregorien hatte sich gestern offen gegen
die russische Militärführung gestellt
und ist in die russische Region Roßdorf
einmarschiert über den messenger-dienst
telegram teilte prigoshi mit alle
militärischen Einrichtungen in Roßdorf
sein unter seiner Kontrolle er wirft dem
russischen Verteidigungsminister vor
Angriffe auf Lager seiner wagnertruppen
angeordnet zu haben und fordert nun
Verhandlungen mit dem
Verteidigungsministerium und dem
Generalstab ja und von russischer Seite
scheint man an diesem Verhandlungen
nicht interessiert zu sein der
Geheimdienst der russische
Geheimdienstes
SB ermittelt gegen und in Moskau und der
Region drumherum wurden Anti
terrormaßnahmen in Kraft gesetzt das
russische Verteidigungsministerium rief
die Kämpfer der wagnertruppe auf sich
von prigoshi abzuwenden jetzt aber erst
einmal der Blick nach Roßdorf eine Stadt
ungefähr 1000 km von Russland entfernt
und der aktuellen Situation dort
militärische Einheiten Rollen durch das
nächtliche Moskau die russische
Staatsführung verschärft ihre
Sicherheitsvorkehrung im ganzen Land
Präsident Putin meldet sich am Vormittag
mit einer Rede an die Nation darin
bezeichnet er die Rebellion des
wagner-chefs brigoshin als Verrat
es ist ein Durchstoß in den Rücken
unseres Landes und unseres Volkes
diejenigen die den militärischen
Aufstand organisiert und vorbereitet
haben die die Waffen gegen ihre
Mitstreiter erhoben haben haben Russland
verraten und werden dafür zur
Rechenschaft gezogen
zuvor hatte der Wagner Chef zum Aufstand
gegen die Armeeführung aufgerufen
Gruppen waren in die südrussische Stadt
Rostow eingezogen und hatten dort
militärische und zivile Einrichtung
unter ihre Kontrolle gebracht darunter
das Hauptquartier der Armee von dort
schickte Söldner Chef rigorchin diese
Nachricht
unter Kontrolle militärische Objekte
einschließlich des Flugplatzes Flugzeuge
die zum Kampfeinsatz starten starten
regelmäßig
nach verschiedenen Berichten sollen
wagnertruppen jetzt in Richtung Moskau
unterwegs sein ja und jetzt kann ich
sprechen mit Juri rescheto er ist Moskau
Korrespondent hat sieben Jahre lang für
die Deutsche Welle aus Moskau berichtet
ist jetzt sozusagen im Exil in Riga in
Lettland und ist uns jetzt per Telefon
zugeschaltet her ricetto die Situation
in Rostock wie müssen wir uns die jetzt
vorstellen also russisches Gebiete
russische Bevölkerung und die
wagner-truppe Söldner die Sollner Truppe
Wagner ist einmarschiert sozusagen was
hören sie aus dem Gebiet
Informationen die wir haben zur
Verfügung nach all den telegram Kanälen
und anderen Social Media Informationen
aber auch von Augenzeugen wissen wir
dass die Lage im Moment in der Stadt
relativ ruhig bleibt die Menschen haben
sich auf dem Zentralplatz versammelt von
Rostock und sind natürlich unzufrieden
aber es gibt keine besonderen Unruhe die
Militärtechnik soll vor dem
Verwaltungsgebäude stehen und es gibt
aber nicht nur Rostock am Donner es gibt
eine andere Stadt die heißt
ebenfalls im Süden von Russland etwas
nördlicher Richtung Moskau dort soll
eine Öl Raffinerie in Brand gesetzt
worden sein und jetzt brennen und auch
ein Hubschrauber ein Militärhubschrauber
ist dort abgestürzt es ist nicht klar ob
er den russischen Streitkräften gehört
oder aber den Truppen von rigorsen
schauen wir noch mal auf die russische
Bevölkerung und auch auf die Moral der
das russischen Militärs da haben wir in
der Vergangenheit immer wieder gehört
die sind müde die sind unzufrieden
dadurch auch so dass so viele junge
Soldaten eingezogen wurden an die Front
was können Sie von dieser Stelle
berichten naja also die russische Armee
ist ja nicht gleich russische Armee da
gibt es eben wie sie richtig sagten die
jungen Soldaten die erkämpfen die ein
Vertrag haben das sollen angeblich keine
ähm ja keinem junge Soldaten sein die
jetzt quasi bei der arme dienen sondern
eben die Vertrag Soldaten und dann gibt
es diese genannten mobilisierten das
sind alles Männer die an die Front gehen
mussten und natürlich auch nicht
unbedingt davon begeistert sind dass sie
dann davon sind insofern kann ich mir
vorstellen dass die Moral da nicht
besonders gut ist es gab auch viele
Berichte und das hat auch schon immer
wieder gesagt davon wie ähm was wir was
für Zustände herrschen sollen also
demoralisierte Armee die auch nicht vor
Wasser vorwärts kommt nicht so ankommt
wir wissen dass die in der Ukraine jetzt
Verteidigungslinien aufgebaut haben und
jetzt nicht darum geht für die russische
Armee nach vorne zu gehen sondern sich
zu verteidigen das war der Blick auf die
russischen Soldaten jetzt noch mal
vielleicht der Blick in die russische
Bevölkerung wie muss man sich das
vorstellen jetzt zum Beispiel auch in
der Region Roßdorf können Sie sich
vorstellen oder hören Sie sogar es gibt
es da sogar Zustimmung vielleicht für
für die Söldnertruppen Erleichterung
weil man unzufrieden ist mit der Politik
überhaupt oder wie muss man sich das
vorstellen also ich glaube ganz sicher
gibt es jede Menge wirklich sehr viele
Menschen in Russland die mit der
Situation unzufrieden sind in dem Krieg
und zufrieden sind mit der Politik und
Putin unzufrieden sind aber extrem
eingeflüchtet worden sind in den letzten
Monaten Russland in einem Jahr Angst
Zustand kann man fast schon sagen und
sich nicht getraut haben etwas zu sagen
ob wir jetzt auf die Straße gehen das
mag ich zu bezweifeln die Angst sitzt
immer noch groß vor der pressalien wir
haben heute auch jede Menge
Solidaritätsbekundungen
der russischen offiziellen Stellen
Richtung Putin gehört vom Föderationsrat
von daduma und von anderen Behörden das
heißt also es ist nicht so dass die
Stimmung jetzt gibt und die Menschen
sagen jawohl jetzt geht es doch endlich
endlich los mit dem put so ist das nicht
also es gibt immer noch wie gesagt diese
diese vereinzelte diese diese Unruhe es
gibt die besorgen ist dass das
eskalieren kann aber dass die Stimmung
jetzt gibt dass ich noch nicht jetzt
schauen wir noch mal auf Moskau selber
es wurden Anti terroristische Maßnahmen
in Kraft gesetzt was bedeutet das für
den Alltag der Menschen in Moskau welche
Handhabe hat Präsident Putin damit
das bedeutet schlicht und einfach dass
die Behörden jetzt runter alles machen
können was sie wollen und dafür eben
keine richterlichen Beschlüsse brauchen
nämlich sie können die Menschen
durchsuchen ohne Befehl wir können
Menschen ähm abhören und auch während
Schriftverkehr
mitlesen ohne Praxis einer wie gesagt
ein extra richterlichen Erlaubnis oder
oder Anordnung bedarf es heißt auch
dieses Dimension jetzt kontrolliert
werden bei den einreisen und ausreisen
aus Moskau es sollen keine Sperren geben
moskau ist nach wie vor frei für ein
Reise- und Ausreise aber es sollen
extrem viele Checks also es sieht
Sicherheitskontrollen geben und deswegen
sind die Schlangen auch an den Straßen
sehr lang und der Stau wie sehr schwächt
der Wegfall der Söldnertruppe Wagner
jetzt ja das Militär in Russland bzw die
Kriegsführung Putin
bedenkt dass die letzten militärischen
Erfolge nicht die reguläre russische
Armee erreicht hat sondern eben die
Truppen von prigosen dann kann man sich
schon vorstellen dass das ja wie Putin
auch selber formuliert hat einen Schlag
in den Rücken auch militärisch wie
gesagt die gegossen Leute sollen
deutlich besser gekämpft haben und
besser ausgestattet sein
dass sie in den letzten Monaten immer
schwächer wurden das hat rigor schon
selbst äh kritisiert er hat ja danach
verlangt mehr Munition zu bekommen mehr
Waffen zu bekommen anscheinend ist es
nicht der Fall gewesen wenn man diese
endlose Schlacht um bachmund nochmal zu
Gemüte führt die geführt wurde Monate
lang dann war eben am Ende präsent der
ja die Stadt erobert hat und nicht die
regulären russischen Streitkräfte sagt
Juri reseto Russland Korrespondent der
Deutschen Welle berichtet jetzt aus Riga
in Lettland danke für diese Einschätzung
ja heute morgen 10 Uhr Moskauer Zeit ca
9 Uhr deutscher Zeit wandte sich der
russische Präsident Putin im russischen
Staatsfernsehen an die Nation Putin
sprach von Hochverrat von einem
Verbrechen einem Dolchstoß der sich
gegen das ganze russische Volk Wende und
zu Beginn seiner Rede hörten wir das
altbekannte narrativ russland werde vom
ganzen Westen angegriffen und bekämpft
das kennen wir mittlerweile dass der
russische Präsident seinen Angriffskrieg
gegen die Ukraine zu einem
Verteidigungskrieg macht und den Westen
zum Täter wir hören rein in die Rede von
Wladimir Putin
ich wende mich an die Bürger Russlands
an die Truppen
an die Rechtsschutzorgane und
Sicherheitsdienste angekommandeure und
Kämpfe die gerade an der Front im
Einsatz sind
und die es für die Helden machen ich
weiß darüber ganz genau heute Nacht zu
habe ich mit den allen Befehlshaber
gesprochen ich wende mich an diejenigen
die durch die Lüge oder Betrug in einer
verbrecherische Avant Türe
hineingezogen sind und die auch den Weg
die haben Meuterei getreten sind heute
steht Russland im schweren Kampf für die
Zukunft sie werden Aggression der
Neonazis und ihrer Herren ab gegen uns
ist praktisch die ganze Maschinerie des
Westens Gerichten die Informationen die
Wirtschaft und die Sicherheits okay das
heißt es wir kämpfen für unsere
Souveränität und Unabhängigkeit für
unser Recht Russland zu sein und zu
bleiben Start mit dem mit der
tausendjährigen Geschichte und heute ist
natürlich die Einigkeit gibt gefragt die
Konsolidation und die Solidarisierung
Solidarität heute müssen wir alles
beiseite legen die uns schwächt alle
quereleien die von unseren außenfeinden
ausgenutzt werden um uns von inneren so
Schwächen deshalb alle Handlungen die
uns Schwächen das ist eigentlich die
Abtrünnigkeit von eigenem Folge von
Kameraden an der Front das ist ein Stich
in den Rücken gegen unser Volk und unser
Heimat genauso
kam es im Jahr 1917 als unser Land im
Weltkrieg stand und als Russland der sie
gestohlen worden wurde also der Verrat
führt
zum Zerfall der Staates und zum
Verzicht auf riesen Territorien und im
Endpunkt änderte sich alles im
Bürgerkrieg als die Brüder die Brüder
getötet haben und profitiert dafür haben
nur die ausländischen Feinde die unser
Land aufteilen wollten wir lassen das
nicht zu dass er sich wiederholt wir
werden unsere Heimat von allen Gefahren
verteidigen darunter von der
von dem inneren Vertrag das was wir
jetzt so tun haben das ist eben der
Verrat die
ausufernden
Ambitionen führten zum Verrat an dem
Volk und an den Kameraden an der
Frontlinie die Helden von
dann war's und solida die mehr die
Kämpfer von Wagner die ihr Leben
abgegeben haben im Kampf in der Ukraine
und dieser Menschen sind auch verraten
verraten worden von diejenigen die die
Menschen jetzt zur Treulosigkeit bewegen
noch mal
jede
innerlicher wäre ist tödlich gefährlich
für uns als eine Nation das ist ein
unser Volk und Nation und unsere
Handlungen zum Schutz der Nation und der
Heimat werden hart sein alle diejenigen
die bewusstlos die mörderei vorbereitet
haben durch die terroristische Maßnahmen
und die auspresst und die Erpressung
werden sowohl vor dem Volk wie auch vor
dem Gesetz verantwortlich müssen die
Streitkräfte unter anderem Staatsorganen
Organe haben notwendige Befehle bekommen
die zusätzlichen Maßnahmen zur
sicherheitssicherung sind in Moskau in
Region Moskau sowie einen anderen
Regionen des Landes getroffen wurden
zusätzliche Maßnahmen werden in Bezug
auf die Stadt Rostock am Donner
getroffen werden die Lage dort bleibt
immer noch kompliziert die Arbeit der
zivil und Militärbehörden sind dort
blockiert worden und als stadtpräs werde
ich alles tun um die Verfassung
Zuordnung das Leben und ihre Freiheit
der Bürger in Schutz zu nehmen die
Organisatoren und strecken sie ja der
Meuterei diejenige die die Waffe gegen
die die Kameraden gerichtet haben haben
das Land für raten und werden dafür
verantwortlich müssen
die anderen rufe ich auf keinen
tragischen Fehler zu begehen und
einzig möglicher Entscheidung zu treffen
die Beteiligung anderen gesetzwidrigen
Handlungen einzustellen ich bin fest
überzeugt wir werden unser Land
verteidigen wir werden alle
Herausforderungen meistern und werden
noch stärker
so das war die Rede das russischen
Präsidenten Putin bei mir im Studio ist
Andreas Heinemann Krüger
konfliktforscher und
Politikwissenschaftler an der
Universität Bonn herzlichen Dank dass
Sie sich Zeit nehmen diesen Tag hier mit
uns einzuordnen wir haben die Rede
gehört und auffallend ist das Putin in
keinem Wort brigochien direkt adressiert
sondern er spricht sozusagen zu den
allgemeinen Verrätern der Meuterei was
steckt dahinter ihrer Meinung nach
er Putin hat ja die ganze Zeit
eigentlich beide gegeneinander
ausgespült also scheuge den
Verteidigungsminister auf der anderen
einen Seite und und pregosch in den Chef
von der wagnergruppe auf der anderen
Seite konnte beide ständig unter Druck
setzen keiner durfte alleine mächtig
genug werden und jetzt kann er diesen
dieses lavieren nicht mehr weiter
praktizieren sondern musst du eine
Entscheidung treffen weil pregorien die
Machtfrage gestellt hat und jetzt hat er
sich auf die Seite sozusagen das
regulären Militärs gestellt aber es ist
ein bisschen wieder ein Zauberlehrling
er hat ja den prigosh ihn selber
geschaffen hat private Militärfirmen
zugelassen das heißt der staatliche
Gewaltmonopol aufgehoben und die
verselbstständigen sich nun und da
sozusagen Opfer seines eigenen seiner
eigenen Kreation geworden
ich denke er wird gewinnen er nimmt die
Situation sehr ernst Vergleich mit der
Oktoberrevolution 1917 gleichzeitig wird
eine neue Legende vorbereitet nämlich
das Durchstoß sozusagen vielleicht Zeit
für die Misserfolge an der Front
zuständig ist also nicht nur die Stärke
des Westens sondern eben auch der innere
Feind also da wird eine neue
Rechtfertigung sozusagen aufgebaut
die Frage ist ob damit die Konflikte die
ja zu dieser Zuspitzung geführt haben
eigentlich gelöst sind indem man jetzt
wahrscheinlich pregorian von Gericht
stellt die Frage ob man ob es dazu
überhaupt kommt oder ob er gleich
neutralisiert wird wie Putin sagt auf
jeden Fall ermittelt der russische
Geheimdienst gegen ihn sie haben eben
gesagt putin wird das Ganze gewinnen
jetzt da sie sind sie sich sicher also
also er wird nach einer Voraussicht nach
die
Konfrontation dieser beiden
gewaltapparate gewinnen und zwar bei
pregorian von der ganzen Logistik her
auch schon eine Vergangenheit immer von
dem regulären Militär abhingen der kann
ja nicht eigene Ressourcen generieren
die Frage ist die ob es jetzt direkt zu
Schüssen von sozusagen russischen
Kämpfern
wagnergruppe auf Soldaten kommt das
heißt zu einer Art von militärischer
Auseinandersetzung das wollen viele
gerade in der Region Rostock am Don
verhindern weil russische Generäle ja
auch mit Wagner zusammengekämpft haben
und kein Interesse daran haben gegen
ihre früheren Waffen Brüder sozusagen
jetzt die die Waffe zu richten ich
glaube auch die Wagner Leute wollen
letztlich nicht mehr bewaffnete
Auseinandersetzung aber unterm Strich
wird Putin sich damit durchsetzen dass
er dass er sagt das Modell Wagner kommt
hier mit zu am Ende die Autonomie von
Wagner wird wird eingeschränkt weil das
ist Hochverrat und
das wird nicht mehr zugelassen also
diese alte Modell ausspielen beider
gegeneinander das kommt hier zum Ende
das heißt sie gehen auch nicht davon aus
dass ich eventuell andere noch prigoshi
anschließen also andere Truppen
vielleicht auch aus dem Militär selber
dass es dazu Überläufen kommt also es
hat ein Reihe anderer privater
Militärfirmen auch gegeben die jetzt
schon heute da über Telegramm Kanäle
mitgeteilt haben sie würden sich mit der
wagnergruppe und viel Georgien
solidarisch erklären
grundsätzlich denke ich trotzdem dass
das eine Frage der Zeit ist bis
sozusagen der staatliche Gewaltapparat
sich da auch durchsetzt wie gesagt weil
die Ressourcen nicht eigenständig
generiert werden können die sind
abhängig aber
es ist so wenn man eine elitenspaltung
die daran dort sichtbar wird und auch
eine Spaltung über die Kriegsziele also
es hat einen größeren Hintergrund die
sind unsicher wofür kämpfen wir
eigentlich pregorian sagt dass die
Kriegsziele sind nicht mehr zu erreichen
wir müssen die minimieren wir müssen von
diesem maximalismus Weg wir können nicht
mit seinem Kampf bis zum Ende führen
wird wir dürfen auch mit dieser Dächern
Informationen nicht mehr weitermachen
mit dem Lügen der eigenen Bevölkerung
diese ganzen Themen die bleiben ja
unabhängig von pregorian bleiben die ja
da das heißt diese Sollbruchstellen die
sind von prigoren sozusagen zugespitzt
worden aber der Konflikt wäre nicht
gelöst indem man
rausnimmt und und entweder vor Gericht
stellt oder liquidiert ja vielen Dank
bis hierhin wir sprechen gleich noch mal
weiter her eine Mann Krüger wir schauen
jetzt noch einmal auf einen Statement
von dem er eben seine Handlungen heute
noch mal erklärt und sich eben offen
gegen die militärische Führung Russlands
stellt
wir befinden uns im Stab der sonder für
Operation ist der 7.30 unter unserer
Kontrolle sind alle militärko Objekte in
Rostow darunter auch der Flughafen da
hat die Militärflugzeuge die an der
Frontlinie im Einsatz sind setzen ihre
Arbeit fort sowie auch die
sanitätsflugzeuge das einzige was wir
gemacht haben also die Kontrolle
übernommen damit die Militärflugzeuge
nicht uns sondern die Ukraine angreifen
die
Leitungsorgane der Streitkräfte arbeitet
wie gewohnt die jeder Offizier ist am
Arbeitsplatz und wir stören die Arbeit
der Stadt nicht und als
als wir hierher gekommen sind sie
mussten wir feststellen er Norbert
Territorien sind verloren worden enorm
Menschen in Massen sind verloren worden
um mehrfach mehr als offiziell bekannt
gegeben wird die
sanitätsverluster pro Tag machen
manchmal bis 1000 Menschen aus das sind
die getöteten die Verwundeten und die
Verweigerer es mangelt an Munition und
es mangelt an der Leitung die Menschen
sind in der gastgasse der Chef des Stabs
ist geflogen worden sofort erfahren hat
dass wir uns dem Gebäude nähern
so da haben wir noch mal
gehört den Chef der Söldnertruppe Wagner
Herr Heinemann Brüder sie sind weiterhin
bei uns sie haben eben gesagt das ist
eigentlich für prigos nicht zu gewinnen
dieser Aktion jetzt dann fragt man sich
warum macht er das trotzdem denn wie das
für ihn ausgehen könnte ist ja auch
eigentlich absehbar warum jetzt also es
gab vorher schon immer Kritik auch an an
der russischen Militärführung auch warum
jetzt dann also begründet wird es damit
dass das russische
Militär die Luftwaffe ein Angriff gegen
einen Wagner Lager geflogen hat und da
durch russische
Luftstreitkräfte eigene Wagner Soldaten
getötet worden sind das ist sozusagen
vielleicht die Provokation sogar von
tschuldigung gewesen das scheuburg
letztlich in diese Situation bringen
wollte wo er die Machtfrage stellt und
sagt so und dann werde ich als scheuburg
zusammen mit Putin diese
Auseinandersetzung gewinnen wenn er
darauf nicht reagiert hätte alles auf
seinen eigenen Kämpfer geschossen wird
dann wäre seine Autorität innerhalb der
wagnergruppe vollkommen untergraben
gewesen das heißt also er hat das
wahrscheinlich auch gesehen als als so
ein Punkt jetzt muss ich reagieren weil
sonst bricht mein ganzes Unternehmen
zusammen das zweite ist das reguläre
Militär hat eben auch immer Alternativen
zu Wagner aufgebaut also
mit dieser privaten militärfirma von von
Gazprom paar Turk aber auch andere die
dann eingesetzt worden sind das heißt
also die Monopolstellung die Wagner in
Zeitlang hatte insbesondere bachmut
Solidar die ist ersetzt worden das heißt
sein Geschäftsmodell war von daher auch
unter Druck geraten und das dritte er
hat erhebliche Verluste zu gewaltigen
gehabt die waren ja praktisch
Kanonenfutter sind auch zum Teil unter
Drogen gesetzt worden um da in die Front
reinzuziehen und so weiter also sie
Verluste waren enorm und insofern konnte
er sich auch nicht mehr so regenerieren
weil die Rekrutierung die Wagner seit
September letzten Jahres in den
strafgefangenenlagern machte jetzt vom
regulären Militär in den
strafgefangenenlagern gemacht wird das
heißt also die Auffüllung der eigenen
Truppen bei Wagner ist erschwert weil
scheuge der Verteidigungsminister lässt
sich das Modell Wagner übernommen hat
interessant also auch dieses dieses
Spiel sozusagen zwischen Show und
prigoshi lassen sie uns noch mal auf den
äh Tschetschenen kadiro schauen wo stell
eigentlich immer Putin treu war jetzt in
der Vergangenheit das bleibt dabei
glauben sie oder ist das auch ein
Wackelkandidat möglicher
also ein Wackelkandidat aber glaube ich
eher nicht weil er hängt ja auch ab
letztlich von von der Macht die im von
Putin zugeteilt worden ist es gab eine
gewisse Arbeitsteilung zwischen diesen
irregulären bewaffneten Gruppen wenn der
Ukraine die kadyro Aufzüge also die
kadurov Kämpfer waren eigentlich die
Truppen hinter der Front die verhindern
sollten das Leute dieser Tieren das
heißt die waren wie im Zweiten Weltkrieg
sondern äh hintere sag mal Auffang
Brigade die
wenn Leute jetzt von der Front geflohen
sind weil die Ukraine Fortschritte
gemacht haben und so weiter und dann
aufgegeben haben und da war für Waren
die Kanüle zuständig letztlich nicht
gegen die Ukraine sondern gegen die
eigenen Leute die bereit sind zu
desitieren oder ein Rückzug zu machen
vorzugehen insofern
ein bisschen anderes Geschäftsmodell
früher waren natürlich die Leute da
schon vor dem Krieg auch so die
killertruppen die für innere und äußere
Operationen genutzt worden sind also so
um
Dissidenten umzubringen was in Russland
gemacht haben aber auch Auftragsmorde im
Ausland durchzuführen inklusive
Europäischer Union oder auch Tiergarten
mords in Berlin aber insofern das
Geschäftsfeld hat sich dazwischen
kadyroof und Wagner nicht sehr
überschnitten was bedeutet das ganze
jetzt für den Krieg in der Ukraine das
ist für die Ukraine jetzt ein günstiger
Moment weil sich der Fokus der
Aufmerksamkeit jetzt gerade woanders hin
richtet oder wie beurteilen Sie das
jetzt sie haben einen gewissen
taktischen Vorteil weil natürlich in
Roßdorf am Don durch die Besetzung
dieses Kommandos in Rosdorf am Don was
zentral ist für Kommunikation und und
für die Sommer Kommandostrukturen über
über diese ganze Frontlinie das wird die
Russen sehr in ihrer inneren
Koordination behindern das werden sie
versuchen auszunutzen dass da unklar ist
wer ist jetzt eigentlich wie wie gehen
die Befehlsketten auf der anderen Seite
glaube ich
das pregorian Wagner zum Ausdruck
gebracht hat dieser Krieg ist eigentlich
in der Form nicht zu gewinnen also
dieser abnutzungskrieg muss irgendwie
beendet werden weil die Erfahrung oder
das was auch pregorian sagt wir können
diese Kriegsziele diese maximalen
Kriegsziele nicht mehr erreichen wir
müssen die minimieren wir müssen uns
vielleicht auf Don jetzt und Johannes
konzentrieren aber diese großen Ziele da
Kiew und endmilitarisierung und
Entnazifizierung und Regimewechsel und
dass sie die Bevölkerung unter Kontrolle
bringen da hat der keine
Illusionen darüber dass diese Leute
nicht mehr zu gewinnen sind selbst wenn
die Russisch sprechend oder ethnisch
russisch sind die sind für Russland
verloren und das anzuerkennen da gibt's
ja eine Fraktion die jetzt sagt wir
müssen raus aus dem Krieg und die andere
Fraktion die vielleicht jetzt gewonnen
hat in Folge dessen die sagt wir kämpfen
mit Putin bis zum Ende insofern würde
ich sagen für die Ukraine taktischer
Gewinn aber strategisch könnte es noch
schlimmer werden weil die Fraktion die
für kriegsbegrenzung ist verloren hat
danke bis hierhin wir sprechen gleich
weiter werfen jetzt aber noch einmal
einen Blick auf diese Söldnertruppe
Wagner um einfach auch noch mal die
Relationen klar zu machen das sind
ungefähr
25.000 Mann die zusammen kämpfen mit der
russischen Armee die aus ungefähr 1,3
Millionen Soldaten besteht davon nicht
alle im Einsatz aber erstmal den den
Blick auf die soldnergruppe Wagner
viel ist über die russische
Söldnergruppe Wagner nicht bekannt sie
wurde 2014 gegründet für den Kampf in
der Ostukraine seitdem sollen
wagnereinheiten in etwa 30 Ländern im
Einsatz gewesen sein unter anderem in
Syrien und Mali laut britischen
Geheimdienst befehle ich die
wagnergruppe bis zu 50.000 Kämpfer in
der Ukraine rekrutiert werden vor allem
ehemalige russische Soldaten und
zunehmend auch Strafgefangene die dafür
annestie erhalten seit vergangenem Jahr
tritt der Oligarch giftgenieurin
offiziell als Chef der wagnergruppe auf
den Söldnern wurden immer wieder
Kriegsverbrechen vorgeworfen in der
Ukraine sollen sie an den Gräueltaten
von Butcher beteiligt gewesen sein
noch einmal einen Blick in die Ukraine
die Kämpfe gehen dort unvermindert
weiter heute Nacht wieder vermehrte
Luftangriffe auf die Ukraine das heißt
auch ja Kämpfer der der Söldnertruppe
Wagner kämpfen weiterhin auch noch gegen
die Ukraine und wir hören wie die Lage
dort ist aus Kiew haben wir den
Korrespondenten Basilika
zunächst einmal dauert der russische
Angriffskrieg gegen die Ukraine an es
gab in der Nacht Angriffe
Raketenangriffe mit mehr als 50 Raketen
auf verschiedene Regionen der Ukraine
auch in Kiew gab es Angriffe und
Explosionen in der Nacht es wurde ein
Wohnhaus von Trümmerteilen getroffen
drei Menschen wurden getötet aus dem
Präsidialamt wissen wir genauso wie von
den Menschen auf der Straße dass sie mit
Interesse die Entwicklungen in Russland
verfolgen präsidente Lenski hat seit dem
frühen Morgenstunden verschiedene
treffen gehabt mit geheimdienstten hat
sich informieren lassen und hat sich so
eben vor wenigen Minuten geäußert hat
von Chaos in Russland gesprochen und
gesagt diejenigen die Hass sehen
bekommen auch Hass zurück und er betonte
auch dass die ukrainischen Soldaten
wissen was zu tun ist die Ziele der
Ukraine bleiben das eigene Staatsgebiet
zu befreien und in Frieden auf dem
eigenen Staatsgebiet zu leben ja dann
schauen wir noch mal wieder Westen auf
die aktuelle Situation schaut eine
Sprecherin der NATO erklärte man
beobachtet das natürlich ganz genau
ähnlich äußerte sich die Bundesregierung
Frankreich Polen und Italien das Auto
ist wertige Amt aktualisierte seine
Reise Hinweise zu Russland und das
britische Außenministerium warnte
unterdessen vor der Gefahr von Unruhen
überall in Russland und forderte
britische Staatsbürger und Angehörige
auf zur auszureisen Michael Grütz aus
Brüssel jetzt mit dem Blick des Westens
auf die Lage
die Staats- und Regierungschefs in den
Hauptstädten der EU aber auch hier in
Brüssel haben sich unisono geäußert und
sagen wir beobachten die Lage genau das
heißt erstmal relativ wenig ist aber
auch verständlich denn die Lage ist ja
überschaubar etwas deutlicher beschreibt
das das britische
Verteidigungsministerium dort heißt es
die Fehde zwischen wagnergruppe und dem
russischen
Verteidigungsministerium ist zu einer
regelrechten militärischen Konfrontation
eskaliert und was man an Bildern bisher
sehen kann ist das auch durchaus
nachvollziehbar und daraus ergibt sich
natürlich die Frage wird trigoshi
möglicherweise Erfolg haben damit oder
wie geht das aus gibt es noch einen
Bürgerkrieg all dies ist extrem
unbestimmt kann im Moment kaum richtig
eingeschätzt werden und entsprechend
sind die zurückhaltenden Äußerungen
natürlich zu werden dann heißt es auch
noch das sei eine innere russische
Angelegenheit das ist natürlich auch
sehr zurückhaltend formuliert de facto
ist das im Moment der Fall aber
natürlich hat das Auswirkungen hier auf
die EU auf die Frage wie geht man mit
Russland und der Ukraine in Zukunft um
und da dies allen noch nicht ausgemacht
ist und noch zu einer viel größeren
Krise führen kann schaut man sich im
Moment die Sache sehr genau an
analysiert und im weiteren Verlauf ist
möglicherweise auch mit weiteren
Reaktionen zu rechnen
so das war Michael Grötz aus Brüssel ja
Herr heinemann-gröter der Westen
beobachtet jetzt wahrscheinlich nur
dabei bleibt es erstmal interessant wird
er zu wird sein zu sehen was macht das
Ganze mit Russland mit der Bevölkerung
in Russland auch
es ist Ausdruck dessen hast ist ein
Kontrollverlust über den Krieg gibt und
das Putin nicht mehr Haar der Lage ist
und insofern ist es Ausdruck einer
fundamentalen Schwäche er ist bisher
eigentlich immer wieder so aufgetreten
dass alle Entscheidungen doch bei ihm
liegen und er die Befehlsgewalt hat und
auch soll man die Kontrolle über die
rotorik hat jetzt muss er plötzlich
vergleichen mit 1917 anstellen das heißt
also dass der Krieg verloren werden kann
wegen innerer Zerrissenheit dessen neuer
ausdruck das wird erheblich zur
Verunsicherung beitragen die
Unsicherheit ob der Krieg zu gewinnen
ist war vorher schon stark also auch die
Symbolik Z ist in Moskau St Petersburg
weitaus weniger zu sehen das heißt die
Unsicherheit womit kann das ganze Enden
sind wir eigentlich in so einer
Situation wie die Deutschen irgendwie im
April 45 das heißt also kommt der
Zeitpunkt wo wir die weiße Flagge hießen
müssen also diese Unsicherheit nimmt in
Folge dessen ganz gravieren zu und das
ganze ist es das kadyra
natürlich eine Karte hier ausspielt die
in der Vergangenheit eigentlich von der
Wahl nie gezogen wurde da waren die war
der Kritiker der Korruption und
plötzlich übernimmt prigogging im
innenpolitischen Kampf die Rolle von
nawalni indem er sagt das ist eine
korrupte Elite des Militär ist irgendwie
verfettet die sind irgendwie Etappen
Offiziere und so weiter das heißt also
hier werden Stimmungen die eigentlich
früher von einer Weine nach 2010 12
mobilisiert worden sind die werden
plötzlich von pregorian wieder
angesprochen das trägt zusätzlich zur
inneren Diskreditierung dieses Putin
Regimes bei das heißt also diese Appell
irgendwie alle um die Flagge herum alle
um Putin herum
das wird für Putin sehr viel schwieriger
einfangen
er kann es eigentlich nur noch durch
Repressionen einfangen das heißt also
die
spezialoperation wird immer mehr zu
einer Fiktion weil der Krieg nach
Russland kommt durch die Drohnenangriffe
ohnehin schon und durch diese russische
freiwilligen Armee die da also mit
ukrainischer Unterstützung auch auf auf
russischem Territorium operiert aber der
Krieg lässt sich nicht mehr sozusagen
fernhalten der kommt zu Hause an bisher
war so in Moskau die größte das größte
Leiden das McDonald's geschlossen wurde
die Situation ist jetzt anders und wenn
sie sagen der Krieg kommt in Russland an
in Moskau an wenn wir uns jetzt
vorstellen wie sich das heute im Laufe
des Tages vielleicht weiterentwickelt
wir haben gehört bewaffnete Einheiten
sind jetzt ungefähr 500 km vor Moskau
ist das ein Bürgerkrieg oder entwickelt
sich da ein Bürgerkrieg heute im Laufe
des Tages
entwickelt weil es eben eine
Auseinandersetzung zwischen zwei Zweigen
der Sicherheitsapparate ist
die Bevölkerung ist da vollkommen außen
vor die weiß auch nicht auf welche Seite
sie sich eigentlich stellen sollte aber
es entsteht der Eindruck einer tiefen
eines tiefen Risses in diesem Regime
einer elitenspaltung das heißt das Bild
wir stehen geeint gegen den Westen das
zerbröselt hier gerade vor den Augen und
wenn es diese Polizei Kontrollen die
Checkpoints eben nicht nur im nordkorker
so viele Vergangenheit oder Grenzen an
Gebieten gibt sondern plötzlich in
Moskau und sagen petersburg dann merkt
man man kann nicht mehr einfach so ein
Park gehen sondern
weil der innere Notstand kommt in der
Hauptstadt an und das ist immer die
große Furcht von Putin gewesen mit dem
mit den nicht russischen Völkern
Kaukasus und so weiter da komme ich um
er hat immer Angst gehabt vor Moskau und
St Petersburg dass die Stimmung da
kippen könnte ja wir werden sehen wie
sich das heute im Laufe des Nachmittags
und Abends weiterentwickelt danke
erstmal für ihre sehr interessante
Analyse bis hierhin danke sehr
ja dann schauen wir noch mal was ich
heute morgen alles ereignet hat im Laufe
des Tages und weitergeht wir haben also
gehört der Chef der Söldnertruppe Wagner
prischogging hat sich offen gegen die
russische Militärführung gestellt und er
sagt er habe die militärische Leitung
der russischen Stadt Rostov übernommen
militärische Einheiten Rollen durch das
nächtliche Moskau die russische
Staatsführung verschärft ihre
Sicherheitsvorkehrung im ganzen Land
Präsident Putin meldet sich am Vormittag
mit einer Rede an die Nation darin
bezeichnet er die Rebellion des
wagner-chefs Gregor schien als Verrat
es ist ein Durchstoß in den Rücken
unseres Landes und unseres Volkes
diejenigen die den militärischen
Aufstand organisiert und vorbereitet
haben die die Waffen gegen ihre
Mitstreiter erhoben haben haben Russland
verraten und werden dafür zur
rechtenschaft gezogen
zuvor hatte der Wagner Chef zum Aufstand
gegen die Armeeführung aufgerufen
Gruppen waren in die südrussische Stadt
Rostow eingezogen und hatten dort
militärische und sie wieder Einrichtung
unter ihre Kontrolle gebracht darunter
das Hauptquartier der Armee von dort
schickte der Chef brigoche in diese
Nachricht
unter Kontrolle militärische Objekte
einschließlich des Flugplatzes Flugzeuge
die zum Kampfeinsatz starten starten
regelmäßig
nach verschiedenen Berichten sollen
wagnertruppen jetzt in Richtung Moskau
unterwegs sein ja und jetzt kann ich
sprechen mit Juri reseto er ist Moskau
Korrespondent hat sieben Jahre lang für
die Deutsche Welle aus Moskau berichtet
ist jetzt sozusagen im Exil in Riga in
Lettland und ist uns jetzt per Telefon
zugeschaltet Herr rechato die Situation
in Rostock wie müssen wir uns die jetzt
vorstellen also russisches Gebiete
russische Bevölkerung und die
wagnertruppe
Söldnertruppe Wagner ist ein marschiert
sozusagen was hören sie aus dem Gebiet
Informationen die wir haben zur
Verfügung nach all den telegram Kanälen
und anderen Social Media Informationen
aber auch von Augenzeugen wissen wir
dass die Lage im Moment in der Stadt
relativ ruhig bleibt die Menschen haben
sich auf dem Zentralplatz versammelt von
Rostock und sind natürlich unzufrieden
aber es gibt keine besonderen Unruhe die
Militärtechnik soll vor dem
Verwaltungsgebäude stehen und es gibt
aber nicht nur Roßdorf am Donner es gibt
eine andere Stadt die heißt ebenfalls im
Süden von Russland etwas nördlicher
Richtung Moskau dort soll eine Öl
Raffinerie in Brand gesetzt worden sein
und jetzt brennen und auch ein
Hubschrauber ein Militärhubschrauber ist
dort abgestürzt es ist nicht klar ob er
den russischen Streitkräften gehört oder
aber den Truppen von rigorsen
schauen wir noch mal auf die russische
Bevölkerung und auch auf die Moral der
das russischen Militärs da haben wir in
der Vergangenheit immer wieder gehört
die sind müde die sind unzufrieden
dadurch auch so dass so viele junge
Soldaten eingezogen wurden an die Front
was können Sie von dieser Stelle
berichten naja also die russische Armee
ist ja nicht gleich russische Armee da
gibt es eben diese richtig sagten die
jungen Soldaten die erkämpfen die ein
Vertrag haben das sollen angeblich keine
ähm ja keine junge Soldaten sein die
jetzt gerade bei der armedien sondern
eben die Vertrag Soldaten und dann gibt
es diese sogenannten mobilisierten das
sind alles Männer die an die Frauen
gehen mussten und natürlich auch nicht
unbedingt davon begeistert sind dass sie
dann davon sind insofern kann ich mir
vorstellen dass die Moral da nicht
besonders gut ist es gab auch viele
Berichte und das hat auch schon immer
wieder gesagt davon wie ähm was wir was
für Zustände herrschen sollen also
demoralisierte Armee die auch ähm nicht
vor Wasser kommt nicht ankommt wir
wissen dass die in der Ukraine jetzt
Verteidigungslinien aufgebaut haben und
jetzt nicht darum geht für die russische
Armee nach vorne zu gehen sondern sich
zu verteidigen das war der Blick auf die
russischen Soldaten jetzt noch mal
vielleicht der Blick in die russische
Bevölkerung wie muss man sich das
vorstellen jetzt zum Beispiel auch in
der Region Roßdorf können Sie sich
vorstellen oder hören Sie sogar es gibt
es da sogar Zustimmung vielleicht für
für die Söldnertruppen Erleichterung
weil man unzufrieden ist mit der Politik
überhaupt oder wie muss man sich das
vorstellen also ich glaube ganz sicher
gibt es jede Menge wirklich sehr viele
Menschen in Russland die mit der
Situation unzufrieden sind in den Krieg
und zufrieden sind in der Politik und
Putin unzufrieden sind aber extrem
eingeschüchtert worden sind in den
letzten Monaten Russland in einem Jahr
Angst Zustand kann man fast schon sagen
und sich nicht getraut haben etwas zu
sagen ob wir jetzt auf die Straße gehen
das mag ich zu bezweifeln die Angst
sitzt immer noch groß oder pressalien
wir haben heute auch jede Menge
Solidaritätsbekundungen der russischen
offiziellen Stellen Richtung Putin
gehört vom Föderationsrat von daduma und
von anderen Behörden das heißt also es
ist nicht so dass die Stimmung jetzt
gibt und die Menschen sagen jawohl jetzt
geht es doch endlich endlich los mit dem
Bus durch das nicht also es gibt immer
noch wie gesagt diese diese vereinzelte
diese diese Unruhe es gibt die besorgen
ist dass das eskalieren kann aber ähm
dass die Stimmung jetzt gibt er sich
noch nicht jetzt schauen wir noch mal
auf Moskau selber es wurden Anti
terroristische Maßnahmen in Kraft
gesetzt was bedeutet das für den Alltag
der Menschen in Moskau welche Handhabe
hat Präsident Putin damit
naja das bedeutet schlicht und einfach
dass die Behörden jetzt im Grunde alles
machen können was sie wollen und dafür
eben keine richterlichen Beschlüsse
brauchen nämlich sie können die Menschen
durchsuchen ohne Befehl wir können
Menschen ähm abhören und auch während
Schriftverkehr
mitlesen ohne das ist einer wie gesagt
ein extra richterlichen Erlaubnis oder
oder Anordnung bedarf es heißt auch dass
die Menschen jetzt kontrolliert werden
bei den einreisen und ausreisen aus
Moskau es sollen keine Sperren geben
moskau ist nach wie vor frei für ein
Reise- und Ausreise aber es sollen
extrem viele Checks also es sieht
Sicherheitskontrollen geben und deswegen
sind die Schlangen auch an den Straßen
sehr lang und der Stau wie sehr schwächt
der Wegfall der Söldnertruppe Wagner
jetzt ja das Militär in Russland bzw die
Kriegsführung Putin
weitere bedenkt dass die letzten
militärischen Erfolge nicht die reguläre
russische Armee erreicht hat sondern
eben die Truppen von prigoren dann kann
man sich schon vorstellen dass das ja
wie Putin auch selber formuliert hat
einen Schlag in den Rücken auch
militärisch wie gesagt die gegossen
Leute sollen deutlich besser gekämpft
haben und besser ausgestattet sein dass
sie in den letzten Monaten immer
schwächer wurden das hat rigor schon
selbst äh kritisiert er hat ja danach
verlangt mehr Munition zu bekommen mehr
Waffen zu bekommen anscheinend ist es
nicht der Fall gewesen wenn man diese
endlose Schlacht um bachmund nochmal zu
Gemüte führt die geführt wurde Monate
lang dann war eben am Ende präsent der
ja die Stadt erobert hat und nicht die
regulären russischen Streitkräfte sagt
Juri reseto Russland Korrespondent der
Deutschen Welle berichtet jetzt aus Riga
in Lettland danke für diese Einschätzung
der heute morgen 10 Uhr Moskauer Zeit
circa 9 Uhr deutscher Zeit wandte sich
der russische Präsident Putin im
russischen Staatsfernsehen an die Nation
Putin sprach von Hochverrat von einem
Verbrechen einem Dolchstoß der sich
gegen das ganze russische Volk Wende und
zu Beginn seiner Rede hörten wir das
altbekannte in narrativ russland werde
vom ganzen Westen angegriffen und
bekämpft das kennen wir mittlerweile
dass der russische Präsident seinen
Angriffskrieg gegen die Ukraine zu einem
Verteidigungskrieg macht und den Westen
zum Täter wir hören rein in die Rede von
Wladimir Putin
ich wende mich an die Bürger Russlands
an die Truppen
an die Rechtsschutzorgane und
Sicherheitsdienste angekommandeure und
Kämpfe die gerade an der Front im
Einsatz sind
machen ich weiß darüber ganz genau heute
Nacht zu habe ich mit den allen
Befehlshaber gesprochen ich wende mich
an diejenigen die ihr durch die Lüge
oder Betrug in einer verbrecherische
agenture
eingezogen sind und die auf den Weg die
haben Meuterei getreten sind heute steht
Russland im schweren Kampf für die
Zukunft sie werden Aggression der
Neonazis und ihrer Herren ab gegen uns
ist praktisch die ganze Maschinerie des
Westens Gerichten die Informationen die
Wirtschaft und die Sicherheits okay das
heißt es wir kämpfen für unsere
Souveränität und Unabhängigkeit für
unser Recht Russland zu sein und zu
bleiben Start mit dem mit der
1000-jährigen Geschichte und heute ist
natürlich die Einigkeit gibt gefragt die
Konsolidation und die solidarision soll
ich da rede heute müssen wir alles
beiseite legen die uns schlecht alle
Quere leihen die von unseren
außenfeinden ausgenutzt werden um uns
von inneren so Schwächen deshalb alle
Handlungen die uns Schwächen das ist
eigentlich die Abtrünnigkeit von eigenem
Volker von der Kameraden an der Front
das ist ein Stich in den Rücken gegen
unser Volk und unser Heimat genau so
kam es im Jahr 1917 als unser Land im
Weltkrieg stand und als Russland der sie
gestohlen worden wurde also der Verrat
führt
zum Zerfall des Staates und zum
Verzicht auf riesen Territorien und im
Endpunkt änderte sich alles im
Bürgerkrieg als die Brüder die Brüder
getötet haben und profitieren dafür
haben nur die ausländischen Feinde die
unser Land aufteilen wollten wir lassen
das nicht zu dass er sich wiederholt wir
werden unsere Heimat von allen Gefahren
verteidigen darunter von der
von dem inneren Vertrag das was wir
jetzt so tun haben das ist eben der
Verrat die
ausufernden
Ambitionen führten schon Verrat an dem
Volk und an den Kameraden an der
Frontlinien die Helden von
dornbas und solida die Kämpfer von
Wagner die ihr Leben
abgegeben haben im Kampf
in der Ukraine und dieser Menschen sind
auch verraten verraten worden von
diejenigen die die Menschen jetzt zur
Treue sich kein bewegen noch mal jede
innerlicher wäre ist tödlich gefährlich
für uns als eine Nation das ist ein
unser Volk und Nation und unsere
Handlungen zum Schutz der Nation und der
Heimat werden hart sein alle diejenigen
die bewusstlos die mörderei vorbereitet
haben durch die terroristische Maßnahmen
und die auspresst und die Erpressung
werden sowohl vor dem Volk wie auch vor
dem Gesetz verantworten müssen die
Streitkräfte unter anderem Staatsorganen
Organe haben notwendige Befehle bekommen
die zusätzlichen Maßnahmen zur
sicherheitssicherung sind in Moskau in
Region Moskau sowie einen anderen
Regionen des Landes getroffen worden
zusätzliche Maßnahmen werden in Bezug
auf die Stadt Rostock am Donner
getroffen werden die Lage dort bleibt
immer noch kompliziert die Arbeit der
zivil und Militärbehörden sind dort
blockiert worden und als stadtpräs werde
ich alles tun um die Verfassungsordnung
das Leben und ihre Freiheit der Bürger
in Schutz zu nehmen die Organisatoren
und strecken sie ja der Meuterei
diejenige die die Waffe gegen die die
Kameraden gerichtet haben haben das Land
für raten und werden dafür
verantwortlich müssen
die anderen Anrufe ich auf keinen
tragischen Fehler zu begehen und
einzig möglicher Entscheidung zu treffen
die Beteiligung anderen gesetzwidrigen
Handlungen einzustellen ich bin fest
überzeugt wir werden unser Land
verteidigen wir werden alle
Herausforderungen meistern und werden
noch stärker
so das war die Rede des russischen
Präsidenten Putin bei mir im Studio ist
Andreas Heinemann Krüger
konfliktforscher und
Politikwissenschaftler an der
Universität Bonn herzlichen Dank dass
Sie sich Zeit nehmen diesen Tag hier mit
uns einzuordnen wir haben die Rede
gehört und auffallend ist das Putin in
keinem Wort
prigoshi direkt adressiert sondern er
spricht sozusagen zu den allgemeinen
Verrätern der Leute rein ähm was steckt
dahinter ihrer Meinung nach
er Putin hat ja die ganze Zeit
eigentlich beide gegeneinander
ausgespült also scheuge den
Verteidigungsminister auf der anderen
einen Seite und und pregorsche in den
Chef von der wagnergruppe auf der
anderen Seite konnte beide ständig unter
Druck setzen keiner durfte alleine
mächtig genug werden und jetzt kann er
diesen dieses lavieren nicht mehr weiter
praktizieren sondern er musste eine
Entscheidung treffen weil pregorien die
Machtfrage gestellt hat und jetzt hat er
sich auf die Seite sozusagen das
regulären Militärs gestellt aber es ist
ein bisschen wieder ein Zauberlehrling
er hat ja den pregorien selber
geschaffen hat private Militärfirmen
zugelassen das heißt der staatliche
Gewaltmonopol aufgehoben und die
verselbstständigen sich nun und da
sozusagen Opfer seines eigenen äh seine
eigenen Kreation geworden
ich denke er wird gewinnen er nimmt die
Situation sehr ernst Vergleich mit der
Oktoberrevolution 1917 gleichzeitig wird
eine neue Legende vorbereitet nämlich
das Durchstoß sozusagen vielleicht für
die Misserfolge an der Front zuständig
ist also nicht nur die Stärke des
Westens sondern eben auch der innere
Feind also da wird eine neue
Rechtfertigung sozusagen aufgebaut
die Frage ist ob damit die Konflikte die
ja zu dieser Zuspitzung geführt haben
eigentlich gelöst sind indem man jetzt
wahrscheinlich pregorian von Gericht
stellt die Frage ob man ob es dazu
überhaupt kommt oder ob er gleich
neutralisiert wird wie Putin sagt auf
jeden Fall ermittelt der russische
Geheimdienst gegen ihn sie haben eben
gesagt putin wird das Ganze gewinnen
jetzt da sie sind sie sich sicher also
also er wird nach einer Voraussicht nach
die
Konfrontation dieser beiden
gewaltapparate gewinnen und zwar bei
pregorian von der ganzen Logistik her
auch schon eine Vergangenheit immer von
dem regulären Militär abhingen der kann
ja nicht eigene Ressourcen generieren
die Frage ist die ob es jetzt direkt zu
Schüssen von sozusagen russischen
Kämpfern
wagnergruppe auf Soldaten kommt das
heißt zu einer Art von militärischer
Auseinandersetzung das wollen viele
gerade in der Region Roßdorf am Don
verhindern weil russische Generäle ja
auch mit Wagner zusammengekämpft haben
und kein Interesse daran haben gegen
ihre früheren Waffen Brüder sozusagen
jetzt die die Waffe zu richten ich
glaube auch die Wagner Leute wollen
letztlich nicht mehr bewaffnete
Auseinandersetzung aber unterm Strich
wird Putin sich damit durchsetzen dass
er dass er sagt das Modell Wagner kommt
hier mit zu am Ende die Autonomie von
Wagner wird wird eingeschränkt weil das
ist Hochverrat und
das wird nicht mehr zugelassen also
diese alte Modell ausspielen weiter
gegeneinander das kommt hier zum Ende
das heißt sie gehen auch nicht davon aus
dass ich eventuell andere noch
prigoschin anschließen also andere
Truppen vielleicht auch aus dem Militär
selber dass es dazu Überläufen kommt
also es hat ein Reihe anderer privater
Militärfirmen auch gegeben die jetzt
schon heute da über Telegramm Kanäle
mitgeteilt haben sie würden sich mit der
wagnergruppe und viel gosin solidarisch
erklären
grundsätzlich denke ich trotzdem dass
das eine Frage der Zeit ist bis
sozusagen der staatliche Gewaltapparat
sich da auch durchsetzt
wie gesagt weil die Ressourcen nicht
eigenständig generiert werden können die
sind abhängig aber
es ist so wenn man eine elitenspaltung
die daran sichtbar wird und auch eine
Spaltung über die Kriegsziele also es
hat einen größeren Hintergrund die sind
unsicher wofür kämpfen wir eigentlich
pregorian sagte dass die Kriegsziele
sind nicht mehr zu erreichen wir müssen
die minimieren wir müssen von diesem
maximalismus Weg wir können nicht mit
seinem Kampf bis zum Ende führen wird
wir dürfen auch mit dieser Dächern
Informationen nicht mehr weitermachen
mit dem Lügen der eigenen Bevölkerung
diese ganzen Themen die bleiben ja
unabhängig von pregorien bleiben die ja
da das heißt diese Sollbruchstellen die
sind von prigoren sozusagen zugespitzt
worden aber der Konflikt wäre nicht
gelöst indem man
rausnimmt und und entweder vor Gericht
stellt oder liquidiert ja vielen Dank
bis hierhin wir sprechen gleich noch mal
weiter wir schauen jetzt noch einmal auf
einen Statement von prigoshi in dem er
eben seine Handlungen heute noch mal
erklärt und sich eben offen gegen die
militärische Führung Russlands stellt
wir befinden uns im Stab der sonder für
Operation ist der 7.30 unter unserer
Kontrolle sind alle militärko Objekte in
Rostow darunter auch der Flughafen da
leider die Militärflugzeuge die an der
Frontlinie im Einsatz sind setzen ihre
Arbeit fort sowie auch die
sanitätsflugzeuge das einzige was wir
gemacht haben also die Kontrolle
übernommen damit die Militärflugzeuge
nicht uns sondern die Ukraine angreifen
die
Leitungsorgane der Streitkräfte arbeitet
wie gewohnt die jeder Offizier ist am
Arbeitsplatz und wir stören die Arbeit
der Stadt nicht und als
als wir hierher gekommen sind müssen wir
feststellen er Norbert Territorien sind
verloren worden enorm
Menschen in Massen sind verloren worden
um mehrfach mehr als offiziell bekannt
gegeben wird die
sanitätsverluster pro Tag machen
manchmal bis 1000 Menschen aus das sind
die getöteten die Verwundeten und die
Verweigerer es mangelt an Munition und
es mangelt an der Leitung die Menschen
sind in der gastgasse der Chef des Stabs
ist geflogen worden sofort erfahren hat
dass wir uns dem Gebäude nähern
so da haben wir noch mal
prigoshin gehört den Chef der
Söldnertruppe Wagner Herr heinem grüner
sie sind weiterhin bei uns sie haben
eben gesagt das ist eigentlich für
prigos nicht zu gewinnen diese Aktion
jetzt dann fragt man sich warum macht er
das trotzdem denn wie das für ihn
ausgehen könnte ist ja auch eigentlich
absehbar warum jetzt also es gab vorher
schon immer Kritik auch an an der
russischen Militärführung auch warum
jetzt dann also begründet wird es damit
dass das russische
Militär die Luftwaffe ein Angriff gegen
einen Wagner Lager geflogen hat und da
durch russische
Luftstreitkräfte eigene Wagner Soldaten
getötet worden sind das ist sozusagen
vielleicht die Provokation sogar von
tschuldigung gewesen das scheuburg
letztendlich in diese Situation bringen
wollte wo er die Machtfrage stellt und
sagt so und dann werde ich als scheuburg
zusammen mit Putin diese
Auseinandersetzung gewinnen wenn er
darauf nicht reagiert hätte alles auf
seinen eigenen Kämpfer geschossen wird
dann wäre seine Autorität innerhalb der
wagnergruppe vollkommen untergraben
gewesen das heißt also er hat das
wahrscheinlich auch gesehen als als so
ein Punkt jetzt muss ich reagieren weil
sonst bricht mein ganzes Unternehmen
zusammen das zweite ist das reguläre
Militär hat eben auch immer Alternativen
zu Wagner aufgebaut also
mit dieser privaten militärfirma von von
Gazprom paar Turk aber auch andere die
dann eingesetzt worden sind das heißt
also die Monopolstellung die Wagner in
Zeitlang hatte insbesondere bachmut
Solidar die ist ersetzt worden das heißt
sein Geschäftsmodell war von daher auch
unter Druck geraten und das dritte er
hat erhebliche Verluste zu gewaltigen
gehabt die waren ja praktisch
Kanonenfutter sind auch zum Teil unter
Drogen gesetzt worden um da in die Front
reinzuziehen und so weiter also sie
Verluste waren enorm und insofern konnte
er sich auch nicht nicht mehr so
regenerieren weil die Rekrutierung die
Wagner seit September letzten Jahres in
den strafgefangenenlagern machte jetzt
vom regulären Militär in den
strafgefangenenlagern gemacht wird das
heißt also die Auffüllung der eigenen
Truppen bei Wagner ist erschwert weil
scheuge der Verteidigungsminister lässt
sich das Modell Wagner übernommen hat
interessant also auch dieses dieses
Spiel sozusagen zwischen Show und
prigoshi lassen sie uns noch mal auf den
äh tschetschenden schauen wo stell
eigentlich immer Putin treu war jetzt in
der Vergangenheit das bleibt dabei
glauben sie oder ist das auch ein
Wackelkandidat möglicher
also ein Wackelkandidat glaube ich eher
nicht weil er hängt ja auch ab letztlich
von von der Macht die im von Putin
zugeteilt worden ist es gab eine gewisse
Arbeitsteilung zwischen diesen
irregulären bewaffneten Gruppen
in der Ukraine die kadyro Aufzüge also
die kadurov Kämpfer waren eigentlich die
Truppen hinter der Front die verhindern
sollten das Leute diese Tieren das heißt
die waren wir im Zweiten Weltkrieg
sondern äh hintere sag mal Auffang
Brigade die
wenn Leute jetzt von der Front geflohen
sind weil die Ukraine Fortschritte
gemacht haben und so weiter und dann
aufgegeben haben und da war für Waren
die Kanüle zuständig letztlich nicht
gegen die Ukraine sondern gegen die
eigenen Leute die bereit sind zu
desitieren oder ein Rückzug zu machen
vorzugehen insofern
ein bisschen anderes Geschäftsmodell
früher waren natürlich die Leute da
schon vor dem Krieg auch so die
killertruppen die für innere und äußere
Operationen genutzt worden sind also so
um
Dissidenten umzubringen was in Russland
gemacht haben aber auch Auftragsmorde im
Ausland durchzuführen inklusive
Europäischer Union oder auch
tiergartenmorts in Berlin aber insofern
das Geschäftsfeld hat sich dazwischen
und Wagner nicht sehr überschnitten was
bedeutet das ganze jetzt für den Krieg
in der Ukraine das ist für die Ukraine
jetzt ein günstiger Moment weil sich der
Fokus der Aufmerksamkeit jetzt gerade
woanders hin richtet oder wie beurteilen
Sie das jetzt sie haben gewissen
taktischen Vorteil weil natürlich in
Rosdorf am Don durch die Besetzung
dieses Kommandos in Rosdorf am Don was
zentral ist für Kommunikation und und
für die Sommer Kommandostrukturen über
über diese ganze Frontlinie das wird die
Russen sehr in ihrer inneren
Koordination behindern dass werden sie
versuchen auszunutzen dass da unklar ist
wer ist jetzt eigentlich wie wie gehen
die Befehlsketten auf der anderen Seite
glaube ich
das pregorian Wagner zum Ausdruck
gebracht hat dieser Krieg ist eigentlich
in der Form nicht zu gewinnen also
dieser abnutzungskrieg muss irgendwie
beendet werden weil die Erfahrung oder
das was auch pregorian sagt wir können
diese Kriegsziele diese maximalen
Kriegsziele nicht mehr erreichen wir
müssen die minimieren wir müssen uns
vielleicht auf Don jetzt und Johannes
konzentrieren aber diese großen Ziele da
Kiew und endmilitarisierung und
Entnazifizierung und Regimewechsel und
dass sie die Bevölkerung unter Kontrolle
bringen da hat der keine
Illusionen darüber dass diese Leute
nicht mehr zu gewinnen sind selbst wenn
die Russisch sprechend oder ethnisch
russisch sind die sind für Russland
verloren und das anzuerkennen da gibt's
ja eine Fraktion die jetzt sagt wir
müssen raus aus dem Krieg und die andere
Fraktion die vielleicht jetzt gewonnen
hat in Folge dessen sie sagt wir kämpfen
mit Putin bis zum Ende insofern würde
ich sagen für die Ukraine taktischer
Gewinn aber strategisch könnte es noch
schlimmer werden weil die Fraktion die
für Kriegs Begrenzung ist verloren hat
danke bis hierhin wir sprechen gleich
weiter werfen jetzt aber noch einmal
einen Blick auf diese Söldnertruppe
Wagner um einfach auch noch mal die
Relationen klar zu machen das sind
ungefähr
25.000 Mann die zusammen kämpfen mit der
russischen Armee die aus ungefähr 1,3
Millionen Soldaten besteht davon nicht
alle im Einsatz aber erstmal den den
Blick auf die soldnergruppe Wagner
viel ist über die russische
Söldnergruppe Wagner nicht bekannt sie
wurde 2014 gegründet für den Kampf in
der Ostukraine seitdem sollen
wagnereinheiten in etwa 30 Ländern im
Einsatz gewesen sein unter anderem in
Syrien und Mali laut britischen
Geheimdienst befehle ich die
wagnergruppe bis zu 50.000 Kämpfer in
der Ukraine rekrutiert werden vor allem
ehemalige russische Soldaten und
zunehmend auch Strafgefangene die dafür
Amnestie erhalten seit vergangenem Jahr
tritt der Oligarch giftgeni brigorchin
offiziell als Chef der wagnergruppe auf
den Söldnern wurden immer wieder
Kriegsverbrechen vorgeworfen in der
Ukraine sollen sie an den Gräueltaten
von Butcher beteiligt gewesen sein
noch einmal einen Blick in die Ukraine
die Kämpfe gehen dort unvermindert
weiter heute Nacht wieder vermehrte
Luftangriffe auf die Ukraine das heißt
auch ja Kämpfer der der Söldnertruppe
Wagner kämpfen weiterhin auch noch gegen
die Ukraine und wir hören wie die Lage
dort ist aus Kiew haben wir den
Korrespondenten Basilika
dauert der russische Angriffskrieg gegen
die Ukraine an es gab in der Nacht
Angriffe Raketenangriffe mit mehr als 50
Raketen auf verschiedene Regionen der
Ukraine auch in Kiew gab es Angriffe und
Explosionen in der Nacht das wurde ein
Wohnhaus von Trümmerteilen getroffen
drei Menschen wurden getötet aus dem
Präsidialamt wissen wir genauso wie von
den Menschen auf der Straße dass sie mit
Interesse die Entwicklungen in Russland
verfolgen präsidente Lenski hat seit dem
frühen Morgenstunden verschiedene
treffen gehabt mit geheimdienstten hat
sich informieren lassen und hat sich so
eben vor wenigen Minuten geäußert hat
von Chaos in Russland gesprochen und
gesagt diejenigen die Hass sehen
bekommen auch Hass zurück und er betonte
auch dass die ukrainischen Soldaten
wissen was zu tun ist die Ziele der
Ukraine bleiben das eigene Staatsgebiet
zu befreien und in Frieden auf dem
eigenen Staatsgebiet zu leben ja dann
schauen wir noch mal wie der besten auf
die aktuelle Situation schaut eine
Sprecherin der NATO Experte man
beobachtet das natürlich ganz genau
ähnlich äußerte sich die Bundesregierung
Frankreich Polen und Italien das Auto
ist fertige Amt aktualisierte seine
Reise Hinweise zu Russland und das
britische Außenministerium warnte
unterdessen vor der Gefahr von Unruhen
überall in Russland und forderte
britische Staatsbürger und Angehörige
auf zur auszureisen Michael Grütz aus
Brüssel jetzt mit dem Blick des Westens
auf die Lage
die Staats- und Regierungschefs in den
Hauptstädten der EU aber auch hier in
Brüssel haben sich unisono geäußert und
sagen wir beobachten die Lage genau das
heißt erstmal relativ wenig ist aber
auch verständlich denn die Lage ist ja
überschaubar etwas deutlicher beschreibt
das das britische
Verteidigungsministerium dort heißt es
die Fehde zwischen pigosch ins
wagnergruppe und dem russischen
Verteidigungsministerium ist zu einer
regelrechten militärischen Konfrontation
eskaliert und was man an Bildern bisher
sehen kann ist das auch durchaus
nachvollziehbar und daraus ergibt sich
natürlich die Frage wird prioshim
möglicherweise Erfolg haben damit oder
wie geht das aus gibt es noch einen
Bürgerkrieg all dies ist extrem
unbestimmt kann im Moment kaum richtig
eingeschätzt werden und entsprechend
sind die zurückhaltenden Äußerungen
natürlich zu werden dann heißt es auch
noch das sei eine innere russische
Angelegenheit das ist natürlich auch
sehr zurückhaltend formuliert de facto
ist das im Moment der Fall aber
natürlich hat das Auswirkungen hier auf
die EU auf die Frage wie geht man mit
Russland und der Ukraine in Zukunft um
und da dies allen noch nicht ausgemacht
ist und noch zu einer viel größeren
Krise führen kann schaut man sich im
Moment die Sache sehr genau an
analysiert und im weiteren Verlauf ist
möglicherweise auch mit weiteren
Reaktionen zu rechnen
so das war Michael Grötz aus Brüssel ja
Herr heinemann-gröter der Westen
beobachtet jetzt wahrscheinlich nur
dabei bleibt es erstmal interessant wird
dazu wird sein zu sehen was macht das
Ganze mit Russland mit der Bevölkerung
in Russland auch
es ist Ausdruck dessen hast ist ein
Kontrollverlust über den Krieg gibt und
das Putin nicht mehr Haar der Lage ist
und insofern ist es Ausdruck einer
fundamentalen Schwäche er ist bisher
eigentlich immer wieder so aufgetreten
dass alle Entscheidungen doch bei ihm
liegen und er die Befehlsgewalt hat und
auch soll man die Kontrolle über die
rotorik hat jetzt muss er plötzlich
vergleichen mit 1917 anstellen das heißt
also dass der Krieg verloren werden kann
wegen innerer Zerrissenheit dessen neuer
ausdruck das wird erheblich zur
Verunsicherung beitragen die
Unsicherheit ob der Krieg zu gewinnen
ist war vorher schon stark also auch die
Symbolik Z ist in Moskau St Petersburg
weitaus weniger zu sehen das heißt die
Unsicherheit womit kann das ganze Enden
sind wir eigentlich in so einer
Situation wie die Deutschen irgendwie im
April 45 das heißt also kommt der
Zeitpunkt wo wir die weiße Flagge hießen
müssen also diese Unsicherheit nimmt in
Folge dessen ganz gravieren zu und das
ist es das kadyra ich brigoschen
natürlich eine Karte hier ausspielt die
in der Vergangenheit eigentlich von
einer walnie gezogen wurde da waren die
war der Kritiker der Korruption und
plötzlich übernimmt pregorian im
innenpolitischen Kampf die Rolle von der
Waldi indem er sagt das ist eine
korrupte Elite des Militär ist irgendwie
verfettet die sind irgendwie Etappen
Offiziere und so weiter das heißt also
hier werden Stimmungen die eigentlich
früher von einer Weine nach 2010 12
mobilisiert worden sind die werden
plötzlich von pregorian wieder
angesprochen das trägt zusätzlich zur
inneren Diskreditierung dieses Putin
Regimes bei das heißt also dieser Appell
irgendwie alle um die Flagge herum alle
um Putin herum
das wird für Putin sehr viel schwieriger
einfangen
er kann es eigentlich nur noch durch
Repressionen einfangen das heißt also
die
spezialoperation wird immer mehr zu
einer Fiktion weil der Krieg nach
Russland kommt durch die Drohnenangriffe
ohnehin schon und durch diese russische
freiwilligen Armee die da also mit
ukrainischer Unterstützung auch auf auf
auf russischem operiert aber der Krieg
lässt sich nicht mehr sozusagen
fernhalten der kommt zu Hause an bisher
war so in Moskau die größte das größte
Leiden das McDonald's geschlossen wurde
die Situation ist jetzt anders und wenn
sie sagen der Krieg kommt in Russland an
in Moskau an wenn wir uns jetzt
vorstellen wie sich das heute im Laufe
des Tages vielleicht weiterentwickelt
wir haben gehört bewaffnete Einheiten
sind jetzt ungefähr 500 km vor Moskau
ist das ein Bürgerkrieg oder entwickelt
sich da ein Bürgerkrieg heute im Laufe
des Tages
entwickelt weil es eben eine
Auseinandersetzung zwischen zwei Zweigen
der Sicherheitsapparate ist
die Bevölkerung ist da vollkommen außen
vor die weiß auch nicht auf welche Seite
sie sich eigentlich stellen sollte aber
es entsteht der Eindruck einer tiefen
eines tiefen Risses in diesem Regime
einer elitenspaltung das heißt das Bild
wir stehen geeint gegen den Westen das
zerbröselt hier gerade vor den Augen und
wenn es diese Polizei Kontrollen die
Checkpoints eben nicht nur im nordkorker
so viele Vergangenheit oder Grenzen an
Gebieten gibt sondern plötzlich in
Moskau und St Petersburg dann merkt man
man kann nicht mehr einfach so ein Park
gehen sondern weil der innere Notstand
kommt in der Hauptstadt an und das ist
immer die große Furcht von Putin gewesen
mit dem mit den nicht russischen Völkern
Kaukasus und so weiter komme ich um er
hat immer Angst gehabt vor Moskau und St
Petersburg dass die Stimmung da kippen
könnte ja wir werden sehen wie sich das
heute im Laufe des Nachmittags und
Abends weiterentwickelt danke erstmal
für ihre sehr interessante Analyse bis
hierhin danke sehr
und in der Zwischenzeit hören wir erste
Stimmen bezüglich des wagneraufstands
der ukrainische präsidentenberater
podoljak hält das Schicksal von
russlands Präsident Putin für offen
möglich sein ein ausgewachsener
Bürgerkrieg ein ausgehandelter
Machtübergang oder auch eine
vorübergehende Atempause vor der
nächsten Phase des Sturzes des
putin-regimes findet er russlands
Präsident Putin wiederum bekommt
Rückendeckung von wichtigen Politikern
die Vorsitzende der beiden russischen
Parlamentskammern und für die von
Russland eingesetzten verwaltungsschefs
in den russisch kontrollierten Gebieten
in der Ukraine brachten ihre Solidarität
mit Putin zum Ausdruck wir werfen einen
aktualisierten Blick auf die Ereignisse
bislang
Kämpfer der Söldnertruppe Wagner
marschieren heute morgen in die
russische Stadt Rostock am Don ein
gerechnet hat damit kaum jemand bislang
haben die Söldner der Privatarmee
zusammen mit russischen Truppen in der
Ukraine gekämpft
wir sind im Hauptquartier es ist 7:30
Uhr morgens wir haben die militärobjekte
von Roßdorf am Don unter Kontrolle
inklusive eines Flugplatzes ob es
Widerstand der russischen Truppen vor
Ort gegen den Einmarsch der seltener
gibt ist unklar die Bevölkerung soll in
den Häusern bleiben schon länger gibt es
einen Machtkampf zwischen dem Chef der
Söldnertruppe Wagner und der
Militärführung in Moskau auf diesen
Vormarsch auf eine russische Stadt
reagiert Präsident Wladimir Putin heute
mit einer Fernsehansprache
Aktionen die unsere Einheit Spalten sind
ein Verrat an unserer Bevölkerung an
unseren Mitstreitern die jetzt an der
Front kämpfen das ist ein deutsch-stoß
in den Rücken unseres Landes unseres
Volkes
wir werden verhindern dass so etwas noch
mal passiert werden unser Volk und
unseren Staat vor weiteren Bedrohungen
beschützen auch vor internen verraten
der russische Geheimdienst FSB ermittelt
nun gegen söldnerchef prigorcin der
Vorwurf lautet bewaffnete Aufstand in
der russischen Hauptstadt Moskau sind
die Menschen verunsichert
es ist erschreckend du sitzt zu Hause
und denkst daran was jetzt passieren
wird man macht sich Sorgen auch um die
Familien natürlich
nein das macht mir keine Angst ich
vertraue auf unseren Präsidenten und
unser Volk die Sicherheitsvorkehrungen
in Moskau sind deutlich verschärft
worden
ja Herr Heinemann Grüter lassen Sie uns
das noch weiter einordnen diesen
Machtkampf zwischen prigoshi und der
russischen Militärführung sie haben
vorhin schon einiges gesagt zum
Verteidigungsminister zum russischen
Verteidigungsminister Show haben wir
noch mal auf die zweite Figur den
Generalstabschef Gerasdorf welche Rolle
spielt der in diesem Trio
ist ja eigentlich der Erfinder dieser
Hybriden Kriegsführung der Ort den Kampf
mit den verbundenen Waffen als die große
Lehrer aus dem Krieg gegen Georgien 2008
gezogen hat das heißt der eigentlich die
westliche Kampfführung als als
reformmaßgabe
zeigen in die Armee eingeführten
insofern ist er anders als scheu gut der
quasi in Lakai ist von Putin und und
politisch auf seinen Posten gekommen ist
aber nicht aufgrund von militärischer
Qualifikation muss man den Giraffen oft
durchaus ernst nehmen weil er eben die
immer Angriffspunkte die Ukraine jetzt
auch in dem Krieg sehr ausgenutzt hat
nämlich die Schwierigkeiten da Atelier
Infanterie
rückwärt hier Dienste Luftverteidigung
und so weiter miteinander abzustimmen
das hat die rassimo oft schon als
sozusagen die Schwäche vor 10 Jahren der
russischen Armee erkannt insofern ist er
eher ein Vertreter der der das
Professionalismus und nicht dieser sag
mal Hauch Kriegsführung für die
wahrscheinlich eher scheu gut steht der
Putin ja auch mit mit
Falschinformationen und mit
Siegesmeldungen zeigen in einer in einem
Optimismus
hineinbegeben hatte insofern auch da
sehe ich noch eine weitere
Sollbruchstelle zwischen scheuge und und
grassimov in Folge dessen jetzt mein
Eindruck ist der
hier hat sich etwas zugespitzt wo es
letztlich darum geht werden wir den
Krieg eigentlich nur noch zum Halten der
Front führen oder wollen wir doch noch
die deklarierten Ziele erreichen wollen
und ich gehe eher davon aus dass die
Rassismus auch weil er den vorherigen
sag mal general abgelöst hatte der
sozusagen der General Aleppo der der
Große flächenbombardierer war das ist
mehr um das halten geht als um
wenn man das Erreichen dieser maximalen
Kriegsziele wenn der aber dann würde er
ja entgegen den Kriegsziel Notdienst
stehen also wie fest oder wie fest steht
dann girassimov oder neben Putin und
Putin treu ist da dann das ist schwer
von außen zu beurteilen es ist jetzt an
einer Stelle aufgebrochen was ich schon
lange Zeit aufgestaut hat aber ich
glaube die Auseinandersetzung zwischen
den verschiedenen Silo Vicky die sind
verschiedenen Vertretern von
machtministerien wird in Folge dessen
noch weiter zunehmen weil
wir können jetzt schon sehen der FFB
wird genutzt um Wagner abzustrafen und
pregorien abzustrafen war aber
gleichzeitig sehr eng mit dem russischen
Militärgeheimdienst Gau das heißt die
Auseinandersetzung zwischen den zwei
Geheimdiensten wird auch in Folge dieser
Zuspitzung jetzt zunehmen das heißt es
knirscht erheblich im Gebälk und ähm
vielleicht kann man das so sagen wenn
man jetzt so eine Analogie machen will
es gab den 20 Juli 44 der ist
niedergeschlagen worden nicht
erfolgreich aber es war das Vorspielen
zu einem Endspiel das heißt also es
könnte auch sein dass der Sieg über
pregorian letztlich doch ein pyrosieg
ist weil das was darin zum Ausdruck
gekommen ist durch das abstrafen und
pregorien wird sichtbar öffentlich
abgestraft auch als Beweis für die
anderen
ihr könnt hier nicht mehr autonom sein
die die Botschaft wird an die restlichen
geschickt aber es könnte im pyroxid sein
weil die Sollbruchstellen bleiben und es
wird interessant sein zu beobachten wie
sich das weiterentwickelt im Laufe des
Tages bis hierhin erstmal herzlichen
Dank für ihre Analyse danke dass Sie bei
uns waren und wir schauen jetzt noch
einmal auf diese Gruppe Wagner die
Söldnertruppe Russlands Schattenarmee
heißt die folgende Doku die wir Ihnen
jetzt zeigen und heute Abend um 17:45
Uhr gibt es eine weitere vor ortsendung
mit aktuellen Meldungen
[Musik]
er hat es sich nie ganz angesehen